l'actualité de ce 12 septembre c'est
aussi cette question faut-il autoriser
le mariage homosexuel c'est en tout cas
le souhait du gouvernement la ministre
de la justice
christiane taubira devrait poser un
projet de loi en octobre christine
boutin présidente du parti
chrétien-démocrate conseillère générale
des yvelines et surtout opposante de
longue date à cette idée demande de son
côté la tenue d'un référendum bonsoir
christine boutin et merci d'être en
ligne avec nous vous avez donc souhaité
déjà obtenir à une audience auprès du
premier ministre est ce que vous avez
été entendue est ce qu une rencontre
sera organisée prochainement
écoutez en même temps je suis pas de
réponse premier thème répond alors vous
souhaitez en tout cas un référendum pour
vous c'est un véritable choix de société
qui se posent les derniers sondages
montrent en tout cas que les français
seraient plutôt favorables au mariage
homosexuel même par l'adoption des
couples du même sexe à quelle est votre
réaction sur ces questions qu'il faut
qu'ils puissent exprimer les sondages et
les sondages ce n'est pas aveugle et je
pense que sur un sujet aussi important
que celui là il convient de consulter
les français et je crois aussi que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire que
c'est un sujet lourd de conséquences sur
l'organisation de la société
il suscite un certain nombre de passions
moi je veux plutôt être une femme de
paix de médiation sur cette affaire et
je pense que pour calmer les esprits de
chacun et le suffrage universel chlorée
le débat c'est à dire le bien gérée
véritablement clos par le suffrage
universel est faite à suffit de
pacification et je pense que dans une
société en crise comme celle dans lequel
nous sommes avec les difficultés de
pouvoir d'achat de logement le salaire
est chez terra d'emploi il faut surtout
pas rajouter les difficultés encore mais
pour vous concrètement vous parlez la
pacification mais si jamais justement il
y avait ce référendum vous feriez
compagne campagne pour le non
on imagine vous êtes engagé contre 7,7
refi
monsieur apparemment apparemment là les
sondages plutôt capitaux battue mais je
suis une démocrate ne sommes pas dans un
état dans lequel il devait y avoir de
débat
donc je pense que c'est important que
chacun porte ses convictions et
justement à partir d'une intelligence à
et pv et bien chacun vote en
responsabilité oui j'ai fait normal de
la république et la démocratie
et si justement il ya ce référendum et
si jamais le justement le oui l'emporté
vous continueriez à vous battre contre
le mariage homosexuel
je dirais que comme j'ai combattu le
paquet je n'ai pas fait et voilà je
pense que c'est la règle du jeu
démocratique
merci christine boutin d'avoir été en
ligne avec nous pour faire un point je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente du
parti chrétien démocrate élu également
au conseil général des yvelines vous
souhaiter la tenue d'un référendum sur
cette question du mariage homosexuel